I'm talking with dr. Christian cobalt of
Dottie Khan Christian there's been a lot
of policy regulatory announcements I
across Europe in the last few months
what does that mean for the market well
it means that regulators are clearly
aware of the role playing in this space
and that they know that they need to
give the market reassurance and
confidence as to where the the
environment will be heading in what
regulatory policies that will they will
be facing there has been some
clarification for example in terms of
the the costing methodology methodology
that will be applied when setting access
prices but there is still an awful lot
to be done I think such as well one of
the main issues that we see at the
moment with with fiber and copper is
that customers really aren't aware fully
of the benefits they're getting from
fibre connections that's partly the
result of advertising that is not
misleading but not entirely clear either
a typical example are the up to speeds
and dsl connections which are rarely
ever achieved in practice so there is
research out there that shows that you
get an average about forty to fifty
percent of the speeds that you think
you're getting after that that a good
many people don't even know what speeds
they have subscribed to and you can see
that coming to the market of the
proposition that you're faster more
reliable service isn't by itself a
winner so there need to be rules that
provide greater clarity in the
marketplaces there is something underway
in Denmark at the moment soft laws that
guide advertising which come into force
beginning of March I understand those
proposals are also being discussed with
the Commissioner we'll see how we get
there but that's one area where we're
clearly a little bit more guidance and a
little bit more confidence would be
extremely helpful well looks as if
there's plenty more to come there is
certainly plenty more to come there is
also plenty more to go I mean we've all
seen that public support public funds
have been drastically reduced connecting
Europe facility has been cut
dramatically the amount of money
available for fiber or broadband has
gone down from about 9 billion to 1
billion so that doesn't leave very much
so clearly as the money gets tight
regulators need to think more creatively
what else they might do in order to help
the business case that is a challenging
business case in face a very good public
policy case but we'll we'll see what
comes absolutely and thanks for talking
to us thank you very much
you